hey guys so before I start with new
theory I want to announce the giveaway
the price of the giveaway is $50 Amazon
gift card in the description below I
shall provide the link and that link
will take you to the website called
gleam and a page will look something
like this
gleam is a webpage that randomly choose
the winner of a giveaway and the
giveaway winner will be announced on
22nd of this month now once you go to
the website it will show you some ways
that you can enter this giveaway it will
be asking you to subscribe to our
Channel and watch a video and more
rangerous you make the bigger chance
you're getting to win a giveaway so yeah
leave a like subscribe or comment
something nice
I wish you all good luck okay guys let's
now focus on new weddings that are we
going to have in the upcoming season by
now we've had a red wedding in which
King Robb Stark was betrayed and
brutally killed along with his wife
Elise and their unborn child
Rob's murdered lady Kathleen V audre
Lorde's along with two soldiers in the
camps including Rob's dire wolf then
we've had a purple wedding in which King
Joffrey Baratheon got poisoned by Petyr
Baelish and Lady Olenna Tyrell on his
own wedding during the wedding feast in
my opinion we're going to have two more
weddings in season seven one between
Cersei and urine and the second one
between sense and Petyr Baelish both of
them will end as these weddings that I
mentioned a few moments ago by my theory
we're going to have the gold wedding
between Cersei and urine which landed
Jaime killing both of them on their
wedding night
Jaime the one who has already killed the
king whom he was supposed to protect
with his own life the one that
sacrificed his honor in favor to save
hundreds of thousands innocent lives
Jaime by my theory once again killed the
ruler whom he is supposed to protect
with his own life but once again he's
going to save a lot of innocent lives
Jaime will kill Cersei Jaime will kill
ones beloved sister and lover as a
result of Cersei deciding not to send
her army to the north to support the
leaning side which her she according to
leaked plot is going to promise to do
Jaime will kill Cersei as a result of
Circe's rejection on Jamie's request the
request in with Jaime will ask her
permission to lead Lannister army to the
north to join the great battle to join
all our enemies but Cersei will refuse
his request along and telling him her
opinion by the
the d'armée which is basically welcoming
the white walkers and their whites which
she sees as a defeat of all her enemies
which would in her opinion only benefit
her Jaime will also kill Cersei as a
result of her marriage with yearn aware
that this marriage means that two armies
the Lannister army and the greater army
one go to the north to support the
living side aver that whole Westeros had
to be Knight and stand as the one to
have a chance against the knight King a
ver of all of that Jaime will decide to
kill Cersei in urine whereupon he is
going to lead Lannister army to the
north to be a part of great battle this
theory of mine I called it gold wedding
you can check out in one of my previous
videos or just click over here to watch
it and then come back and check the
wedding number two the wedding between
Sansa Stark and Petyr Baelish the
wedding that one tenth as Littlefinger
wants the wedding number two will happen
upon Littlefinger's threat to Sansa that
he will put the well troops back to the
well a less sense americium well Jon
Snow it is poem B&V no foul Jon will be
a dragon stone you might think that
Littlefinger Kundun command to the
Knight of the Vale but be careful about
that and remember what happened in the
fourth episode of season six
don't forget the Knights of the Vale
Rameau belies don't because of Peter
only because of his methylation towards
Lord Robin you might say that other
Lords from the well such as yon rise the
Lord of Runestone could decide to stay -
how Jon Snow the matter of little
fingers opinion but you're wrong if some
of the lords from the well wouldn't obey
Peters commands they would be sentenced
to death by the Lord of the Vale by Lord
Rob Baron by the Lord who is manipulated
and as as Peter says the Lord that
mobilized the knights would avail only
because Littlefinger wanted the Lord
that almost threw the head of house race
out of the moon door owned because Peter
won and in first place a little finger
also spared his life which means that
the fate of Lords from the Vale are in
Littlefinger's hands no matter that Yan
Royce was very good friendly tedder
stark with whom Royce hunted many times
no matter if he and other Lords from the
whale want to support how stark all the
lords from the Vale are vassals of house
Aaron and he had to do as Lord of the
well Lord Robin commands or
is day would be executed by this theory
sensible except Peters marriage proposal
and you have to know that at this point
sense is not alone and the winner felt
there's also Arya Stark who will already
meet the Brotherhood without banners and
the hound whereupon the Hound is going
to tell her the truth about Littlefinger
the truth about Peters betrayal and Ned
Stark as this theory goes sensible
actually Mary Petyr Baelish leading to
their wedding night now you might wonder
why would little finger even want marry
Sansa why would he insist that much well
we all know his plans we all know about
his picture that he has in his head the
picture and thoughts that he shared with
Sansa in season six finale the picture
in which she sees him on the Iron Throne
and sense about his side also
Littlefinger wants to marry Sansa
because he is still going to try to make
her rule or Winterfell and the Queen in
the north you might be confused at this
point and I understand that just wait a
little bit more Petyr Baelish
from the very beginning wanted to make
sense as the heir of Winterfell which
along with his idea to marry her will
give him the northern army the big
amount of soldiers that he needs in
favor to make his goal into reality in
favour to be in the Iron Throne
from the very beginning Peters plan was
to kill every stark except Sansa vo
known that Ned was killed because of
Baelish my little finger also tried to
kill bran stark Jaime Lannister bush
branded window press a scene with the
Valyrian steel dagger was sent by
Littlefinger which almost caused Brown's
death Petyr Baelish might have organized
red wedding as well since he was at
Harrenhal negotiating with Tywin
Lannister which could mean a little
fingers genius mine orchestrated red
wedding which would mean the
Littlefinger killed Robb Stark which led
to one less male heir of how stark if
you're wondering why Peter didn't try to
kill Jon Snow the current rule of NFL
and the king in the north
well the answer is simple Littlefinger
didn't consider John as his rival mostly
because of the facts on is considered to
be snow a surname of every bastard in
the north Peters conversation it's an
side godswood of NFL confirms it Peter
said to Sansa
you my love are the future of House
Stark who should the north
why behind trueborn daughter of Ned and
Catelyn Stark born here at Winterfell
or a motherless bastard born in the
south from Louisville fingers point of
view he has done everything to get sense
as the arrow window fell which brings me
at all that Littlefinger will try to
kill Jon Snow brings me at all that bit
Baelish will do his best will try as
best as he can to make it happen now
that there is the only one man in his
opinion that is an obstacle to make his
goal come true Littlefinger's plan will
be to arrange Jon Snow's death while he
will marry Sansa to make sure that this
time after he kills the last man
connected with how stark after his set
sense as a rule winner fell to make sure
that Sansa is his wife the wife which
she will by his plan manipulate bit as
he is manipulating with Lord Robin which
would bring him the northern army
leading him one step further on
conquering the Iron Throne the little
finger won't be aware that sense is
manipulating him that sense I found out
from Arya that he is responsible for
Ana's beheading that's the moment in
which the wedding between sense and
bigger is going to happen the moment
which will lead to their wedding night
which is all planned by two stark
sisters by science and Arya by a little
finger and senses are alone in their
room while Petyr Baelish is convinced
that his picture of them together has
finally came true that very moment by
this theory sense that'll put the dagger
down Littlefinger strode the moment in
which sensible entered the room the
moment in which we have two senses the
moment in which Arya is taking off
senses faced while holding a dagger on
Peters throat very Poenari is killing
him while senses watching I'm aware that
most of you right now are questioning
the accuracy of this theory I'm aware
that most of you think that Arya can't
wear someone's face if that person is
alive but you're wrong back in the final
episode of season 5 there was a scene in
which jaqen H'ghar were arias face the
scene in which jackeen poisoned himself
the scene in which Arya became blind for
a while that's in confirmed that the
faceless man assassins can wear the face
of a person that is not dead a person
that is still alive which makes this
theory in which Arya is using census
phase and killing Littlefinger or senses
entering the room much more possible
I had to admit this story would fit
perfectly to the Game of Thrones series
what do you guys think about this
wedding between Sansa and peter baelish
which would have vittorio killing
Littlefinger using census faiths on
their wedding night do you think that
this Littlefinger's fate would be a
suitable dad for the man who is
responsible for almost every event in
Westeros during the war of five Kings
the man that drew the Seven Kingdoms in
the state of chaos from which he
personally benefited the man that with
his Amish nations destroyed one house
and almost destroyed few other houses do
you think that his dad would be suitable
for him in my opinion this story could
come true considering the previous
events and that's mostly considering the
writing of co-creators David Benioff and
Dan Weiss if this story comes true what
color do you think would label this
wedding don't forget that we've already
had red and the purple wedding and dead
by Tyrion mine we're going to also have
the gold wedding so these scholars are
not available and yeah don't forget to
enter the giveaway just like the link in
the description and follow the entries
all you have to do is basically
subscribe like and also don't forget to
turn on that notification bar next to
subscribe button so you can be notified
every time I upload a video hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace
[Music]
you